tal y como se esperaba Manuel majó
anunció el fin de la operación en el
Azael y de aquí a seis meses él explicó
que después de poder Consultar con los
diferentes socios los diferentes países
africanos diferentes organizaciones pues
dará a conocer Cuál es la nueva
estrategia de Francia en ese en ese
continente por ahora y todavía 3000 al
soldados en níger a Chad y burkina faso
Pero él explicó que de todas maneras la
presencia de las tropas francesas no
Debería ser sin digamos indefinidamente
también a lo largo de ese discurso que
pronunció la ciudad de tuluá aprovechó
para reiterar que la disociación nuclear
por parte de Francia es vital para el
equilibrio de Europa y anunció también
reforzar Los lazos en cuanto estrategia
defensiva con Alemania pero también con
el Reino Unido con el Reino Unido de
hecho espera poder discutir de de
estrategias en cuanto a operación en
cuanto a capacidad también ha sobre el
entre otros y que a principios del
próximo año los tres primeros meses debe
realizarse una Cumbre franco británica
para hablar al respecto